what personality traits are filmmaker
friendly flexibility absolutely you have
to be and willing to willing to know
that you don't know everything yeah well
I mean I think there's that a great
quote from but yet had the confidence to
ya do something you don't mean so the
this melon yeah but there's a great
quote from Kurosawa i think it was like
his 80th birthday party or something and
someone says asked him when are you
going to stop making movies and his
response was when I look figure out how
to make one like yeah I think being a
ferocious student yes a ferocious
student and what you want to do and
constantly be learning yeah yeah yep
just be a sponge of everything yeah and
then you know like some kissing giri and
diplomacy is not a bad idea well so I've
had to learn because I do have a
legitimately have control it control
issues it but I've also ready to be good
yeah yeah I've also just learned to give
give up to get to trust and give over
some of that in it it was really it's
been strange because with our first
feature film the nerves of that world
premiere were so thick because I feel
like we had so much to prove because
we've done so much ourselves and then on
the second one it was weird i literally
I was like I'm not nerv
and I was trying to figure out why I'm
not nervous it is because I literally
feel like the proud parent at a talent
show being like that look at my kids
that's what they did because I we
literally this time brought this team
together and let them do what they all
do so amazingly well yeah and so it's
not even it's not us it's it's it's
these people did this and it's in so
it's not yeah it's a whole different
experience so it's a wonderful feeling
yeah yeah I mean Chris do you have
anything to add to that was really
beautiful what you said their Lindy I
agree well no I mean you know it I mean
Donner so our first feature i was the DP
and the editor and the director and you
know a million other things that it was
a semi-autobiographical story yeah and
you know we wrote it and yeah but no it
was fantastic like not I don't know just
not having to worry about those elements
as my Hannah that's not coming out right
but it was just yeah it was just meant
like the first frame the movie came up
and I was like I'll right yeah this is
good right good I'm not nervous anymore
yeah yeah
you